in America we tend to think that the
news is all about us all the time at
some level you really can't blame us
though just turn on CNN or Fox News or
MSNBC and all you get these days is
endless election coverage with like a
tiny bit of national news and maybe a
minute and hour on the international
front occasionally when something big
flares up the Talking Heads will focus
on Syria or North Korea or Iran for a
couple days but then it's quickly back
to the usual grind even when something
huge like drags it is happening we
barely talk about it in the US until the
very last second when suddenly every
pundit who hasn't mentioned it once in
the past year is supposedly an expert
beyond hearing about terror attacks we
barely even talk about the countries we
have the most in common with once the
initial response to the attack is over
has anything happened in the UK since
brexit what's been happening in France
since the Paris attacks
how are the tapas in Spain or the pasta
in Italy or the cheese in Denmark you
might know and I might know but I bet
it's from alternative news sources and
social media and not from mainstream
television the danger of only hearing
about other countries when bad things
happen like terror attacks riots and
scandals is that you begin to think
that's all that there is to these other
places as well as the citizens that live
there themselves imagine if other
countries only associated Americans with
our current election menu already do and
that is pretty shitty although possibly
warranted every country on Earth every
single one has elements in it that are
good and that are bad this doesn't mean
that every country or every culture is
equal this is not the case but every
country is made up of all sorts of
people with all sorts of beliefs as I've
said often on this show the ultimate
minority is the individual judging an
entire group as a collective will almost
always assure you dismiss huge amounts
of people who don't fit the stereotype
or the narrative I've said this before
and I'll say it again one of the things
that I'm most proud of about the Rubin
report is that our audience is truly
worldwide when we did our fan show a
couple months ago we got messages from
people in over 60
country's we chose people based on their
individual attributes not because we
expected them to represent an entire
nation while our mainstream media does a
pretty poor job of showing that we have
more in common than what separates us I
find that people like you the ones
watching this right now do an incredibly
good job of it the conversations I see
you having in the comment sections right
here on Twitter and on Facebook or even
on your own YouTube videos are
connecting people from all over the
world I see you guys constantly trying
to cut through the nonsense and have
real conversations and find some common
ground together is the only way that
we'll have a chance to truly be heard
my guest this week is Australian
journalist Rita Panahi Rita grew up in
Iran in a Muslim family and emigrated to
Australia when she was 6 years old she's
now a fierce defender of Western values
and spends much of her time writing
about the same issues I talk about on
the show we're going to talk about her
childhood in Iran as well as her life in
Australia is there more to that giant
island country than just boomerangs and
kangaroos I suspect there might just be
to prove my earlier point when was the
last time you heard anything in the news
about Australia since the terrorist
attack in Sydney almost two years ago
they had a nationwide election about two
months ago but I think I only heard
about that because of a random link on
Twitter if you're watching this you're
you've already shed much of the
mainstream nonsense but our work is
still cut out for us let's keep talking
to interesting people from all over the
world and if you've got suggestions well
there's a comment section right down
below
Reeta Panahi is a journalist who was
born in america spent her first years in
iran and has lived in australia ever
since Rita welcome to the Rubin report
thank you for having me greetings from
Melbourne greetings from Melbourne
greetings from Los Angeles I would I
want to dive into some Australia stuff
because we never hear anything about
Australia in America I mean nothing
since Crocodile Dundee - we haven't
heard anything from you guys but let's
start a little bit with your history
because you have a really interesting
history you were actually born in the
United States but you never lived in the
United States correct no not really I
spent my first couple of years there my
parents were there my dad was studying
he was getting his degree in Arkansas so
I was born in down in Pine Bluff
Arkansas and then we moved back to the
Iran which was always the plan and then
the Islamic Revolution happened so
things went pear-shaped here and quite
quickly and we were sort of a trapped
now in a country that was entirely
different to before the Revolution and
ended up in Australia and I'm really
grateful to be here really so it's a
wonderful place and I you guys think
America's the center of the world but I
really think Australia is the lucky
country as we call it and you know
anybody couldn't do well in this country
yeah and I've heard you say that in
speeches before that you really think
Australia is the the true place of
Tolerance and where everyone can come
and make a better life and all that sort
of stuff so your parents so they moved
to to the state say your dad was
teaching or something right um well when
he was in the States he was getting his
degree so he was at university and as
soon as he graduated they moved back
that was always the plan and and then
when Iran went to hell after the Islamic
Revolution they started looking at how
they could get out because they were
fairly persecuted there and they they it
just wasn't safe when we had family
members walked up our family members
killed it was really hell on earth for
our family so
we were looking to leave and the plan
was always to come back to the states
but my dad had a brother in Australia
and we ended up here it wasn't the plan
but it was a lucky lucky chance yeah
people don't realize that before the
Islamic Revolution I mean Arad was a was
a widely secular state in a lot of ways
much more secular than it is now I know
you were really young when you were
there but what are your memories from
being five or six years old
look all the family minted memories baby
yeah it was one of the more western
parts of the Middle East you know you
look at pictures of Tara and back in
before the Revolution and you know you
said women in miniskirts and men and
women mixing freely and women at beaches
you know we used to live by the beach
before we're in Tehran and then things
changed dramatically you know it really
brings home just how quickly things can
degenerate into what we see now I mean
Iran's progressed a little bit from when
the Revolution first happened as far as
its treatment of women but it's still
pretty bloody poor yeah I remember
having to go to school and then suddenly
going from being fairly carefree and not
having to cover my hair to being in an
age we were at five six years old where
you know that was a time when I had to
wear the hijab that was a requirement
and it was just completely dehumanizing
and I just liked that I liked that
change you can just in my little life
from when I was running around with the
boys and being a regular kid to being
expected to observe these moral codes
like making sure my hair's covered and
behaving in a certain way so even as a
at a tender age I felt the force of it
always knew I was an American citizen so
for me are always identified as someone
other than someone had to live the rest
of their life under that oppressive
system so it was it was significant for
me and I was like me and one of the
original anchor baby because I was like
I can get out one day when I'm 18 I'm
not gonna have to pay here so that
really was a source of comfort to me
even as a very young child that one day
I'd get out of this what a fascinating
time to grow up because it's not like
people having their formative years when
there isn't change where you just were
going through what you had to go through
but to go from even though you were very
young to having memories of freedom and
that then as a five-year-old or whatever
that you you knew something was wrong
with being forced into that kind of
system that's it and you know and even
now that kids empty through the young
girls you know for the first few years
they don't have to cover up and they can
run around and they don't have these
obligations on them but when they start
school then hijabs have to be warned and
you know they're you know not the best
things when you've got a stinking hot
day never mind the rest of the year and
yeah breaks my heart when I say that
when you see the kids the girl's
particular having to you know transition
from just being a kid and to being you
know part of the regime yeah what was it
like to actually get out I mean you said
your dad had a brother in Australia well
I assumed the regime probably didn't
want their their bright young people to
leave no I know I we were really lucky
to be accepted in Australia my mum was a
mid wash it was a actually she was the
head Midwife at a hospital there that
was attended by the royal family before
the Islamic Revolution there was a lot
of pictures of her showing the royal
family around the facilities you know
that was a fairly regular thing with
their come and visit and she'd be the
one responsible it has been a big like
glamour person you know look the part so
they really feared for their life
because there were publications and
pictures of her with with the royal
family and you think that might be a
minor thing people got killed for that
you know people we know got imprisoned
so we were lucky to like I said the
intention wasn't
stay in Australia but ended up staying
here and were graduate asylum and it was
just you know yeah forever in debt
indebted to the country because of that
because he gave us a chance in your life
yeah what kind of culture shock was that
like a six year old going from Iran in
the Middle East to an island with you
know people in 40 shorts and all that oh
absolutely and the language was a shock
too because even though I was born in
the States
I had zero English because I you know
been brought up in Iran so I had like
two words hello and T which is a weird
combination of words to know so I had to
learn the language very quickly but it's
such a you know welcoming place and
thankfully English is a very simple
language for a child to learn so it only
took a few months and and yeah it is a
bit of a culture shock but Australia is
not that different that thing you guys
imagine honey guys think they mean
everybody anger is you know just hopping
around that I assume you have a
boomerang within reaching distance of
you right now always I'd never leave one
without a boomerang you never know when
you need it yes yeah it was a culture
shock definitely part you know you
immediately felt safe and very quickly
you realize you know this is a really
welcoming you know wonderful place to to
grow up and so much opportunity yeah did
you experience any discrimination or
anything like that or really was it just
simply you were there years I'm not baby
and after like over 30 years so you know
I have seen occasional discrimination
but really it is minor and it's been
quite often there the discrimination I
see are from your you know your bloody
social justice warriors it supposed to
be the most tolerant you know
open-minded people in the world but if
you don't conform to their idea of what
a brown person should be saying and
doing and thinking then that quite often
really vicious and beneath that thin
veneer of goodness
is is a bigot and I've seen that quite a
lot on Twitter and that's probably the
most racism under her face has been on
Twitter from from the lunatic left right
because you're because somehow you're a
brown do you do identify as Muslim and
you consider yourself X Muslim or do you
consider yourself Muslim or I'm not even
call myself eggs X Muslim my family I'm
Muslim like if you asked them what's
your religion that's a Muslim but
they're very very relaxed about it
they're Muslim in the way most
Australians are Christian it's one big
difference between Australia and America
where a lot less religious than you guys
and and so but I surely as I could
remember identified as atheist I just
didn't believe and so for me there
wasn't a real big transition from being
a Muslim to being an agnostic or an
atheist because I never was practicing
you know I don't think my parents have
ever been to a mosque certainly not me
so they're not at all devout so that's
interesting that the the discrimination
which you face what you're describing is
very little and mostly on Twitter which
is not reality I keep trying to remind
myself that Twitter is not reality but
you're getting it you're getting the
discrimination from the the social
justice crew because you're not you're
not their type of brown person because
you do speak your mind absolutely it is
extraordinary of these people who
supposedly spend their lives fighting
for the for the minorities that you know
they say is perpetually oppressed even
in countries like Australia when and
when are you actually speaks up and has
their own thoughts that they and it
doesn't conform to their worldview they
are absolutely appalling in in their
response straight-out
bigotry and you know it's like if you're
in a certain race or if you have a from
a minority group you should only vote a
certain way you know you're not allowed
the opportunity to think of yourself and
decide for yourself who who you're going
to support or where you're going to
stand on certain issues and yeah like I
said but beneath that thin veneer of
virtue
quite often there's a really hateful
bigot when someone is you know
identifies as a social justice warrior
and I've got no qualms about mocking
them day and night I just think that
quite often horrid people who deserve to
be called out yeah and and you get a lot
of crap for calling them out but it
doesn't stop you but I agree of course I
mean it's such a dim view of the world
that they have that we should only
viewed in this collectivist space but
before we go all in on that stuff tell
me a little bit about Australia cuz
boomerangs and kangaroos and reverse
Coriolis effect in your toilet aside I
feel like nobody in the States knows
anything about Australia you're a big
island that's pretty much it
well we're a big island most of the
population lives along the coast love
desert in the middle it's a really
modern I think it's a lot like the
States except we're not really just
that's one of the things we look at you
and we don't sort of identify when we've
had a prime minister who was an atheist
and we had no issue with that at all I
mean she was a terrible prime minister
but not because she was an atheist
nothing to do with me regardless no I
had nothing to do with it
we've had a lot of prime ministers
recently we've had a modern history of
being really stable particularly
politically but in the last six seven
years we seem to just keep knifing our
prime ministers they get elected and
then their own party nice them and then
we have another one so that's quite a
characterize the politics in recent
years I'm quite a conservative
government at the moment but led by a
man who many conservatives don't really
see as a conservative so it's a really
interesting period and he just hung on
because a lot of the conservative base
abandoned their party and went and voted
for minor parties so it's really
interesting seeing what's happening
around the world you know with you guys
because there does seem to be this
uprising from from conservatives where
they don't actually think the the major
party is or the major establishment I
guess isn't really representing their
interests and in Australia we had you
know a lot of minor parties and some of
them described as far-right
a lot of whites in the last election
this year yeah so I think Americans
think that everybody is like us like oh
we're a two-party system even though I
keep saying on this show the
Constitution never says anything about
only having two parties it's just that
the two parties have a strangle in our
system you guys have a bunch of parties
that sort of trade power and and it's
not just two parties on top of
everything right that's right well we've
got a labor which is a predominant Left
Party and then we've got the
Conservatives which are liberal and
national and they are in a coalition
together and then we've got a minor
party called the greens which they get
like one in ten votes so in the Senate
our house they have to have a presence
but this last election the minor parties
from all weird facets you know the House
Senate is an absolute devons breakfast
you know is I'm gonna be fascinating to
see how we can govern for the next few
years because you've got so many Mike so
many minor parties that I have got their
own little objection objectives and you
wonder how they're gonna work together
and agree and pass legislation so so
yeah we do we have a very different
system to you it's a party based system
we don't vote for our for a leader Prime
Minister we vote for our representative
in our local seats so it's a little bit
different um but though we don't
directly vote for the Prime Minister it
whoever is leading the party is
significant obviously and has a fair
fair deal to do with who gets elected
yeah so it's kind of there's benefits
and drawbacks to both right because here
yeah that there is there is um and you
know you've got particularly in this
Senate when you've got so many different
parties no you can't have the vote
diluted and our Senate is a really weird
system every single stage is entitled to
the same number of senators so you might
have a very populous state like New
South Wales or Victoria but we get the
same number of Senators as Tasmania
which is
who's there so it's not a one vote one
value so it's it's it's mad I mean I I'd
be very much for abolishing our Senate
our house because it's very much
obstructionist and unrepresentative but
that ain't gonna happen anytime soon
it's an argument that's been made
decades and and you know it's still
there
right I'm curious being an island I mean
being just a the fact that you guys are
so big geographically and that you're
and I and how much of that actually
plays into sort of the national ethos
because you know like when we see what's
going on with the European Union and
borders and all that stuff these are
people that are landlocked next to each
other you know borders and immigration
are important all that kind of stuff and
you guys really have the advantage of
water I mean it really is just that
simple in way but how much is that
actually like affect policies and the
way people think about the rest of the
world and all that kind of stuff oh look
we've got oceans and yeah geographically
we are blessed to be apart from a lot of
that turmoil but those oceans didn't
stop 50,000 people coming here by boat
when labor was in government we had a
very strict border control system under
the Conservative government of John
Howard and when labor were elected they
completely dismantle that because that's
not that wasn't in their thinking they
thought it was more humane to to be a
little bit more tolerant but that
tolerance led to hundreds of people over
1200 people drowning on our borders
trying to come here from places like
Indonesia bye-bye they weren't
Indonesians they'd travel form typically
the Middle East right so there are
migrants actually from other countries
that use Indonesia's right keeping the
economic migrants I'm sure there was
some genuine refugees amongst them but
the overwhelming majority you would
describe as economic migrants and even
the Labour Party came to acknowledge
that and they started toughening up and
right now they're well they say they
back all the border protection policies
that the conservative side have and and
you know they're not they're not going
to dismantle everything because it led
to
you enormous suffering not just the 1200
people we drowned trying to get here
women and children amongst them but also
all our detention centers filled you
know we have to do that we have just
fifty thousand I've been given more than
that in detention centers you know
effectively locked up and since we've
managed to take regain control of our
borders those detention centers have
emptied out there's not people drowning
on the border and we still have a
refugee program we still have a
humanitarian intake in fact we've
increased it but we select people who
are waiting and observing the rules
because you know what people there was a
period where people would argue that
there are no queues to come here you
know these programs don't exist but as
we know they do exist and there's people
floundering waiting in camps who don't
have the resources to hop on a plane to
Indonesia and then pay a people smuggler
to come by boat to Australia and then
our priority so we a refugee intake I
think is something to really be really
proud of because we are very generous
with that and you know this isn't just
simply porous borders this is a proper
humanitarian program where these people
are brought here they're given housing
health care education and you know help
to to become integrated into society but
Rita Rita I thought you were supposed to
be a cold-hearted heartless conservative
who wants to close borders and all that
but it it sounds like you're actually ok
with immigration as you were an
immigrant yourself but you just want you
just want reasonable standards to let
Emma we've got this country particularly
economically needs our economic migrants
they bring a great deal of wealth and
you know we're an aging nation we need
people to who are working age and come
here and are productive and contribute
well our humanitarian intake we've got
to be honest it cost us a lot of money
but it is something I think that as a
rich nation were obliged to do and I'm
proud of that however that doesn't mean
that it's a free-for-all and whoever you
know I can just break the rules come
here can come here first also we've got
to be mindful of where those refugees
are coming from
because of late there has been issues
with some not integrating as they should
and as immigrants decades before them
have integrated so there is a lot of
debate in this country about where
should these refugees come from you know
where do we do we prioritize Christians
who being persecuted in in the Middle
East CZTS or do we not consider religion
at all and just bring in whoever's you
know deemed the neediest there was a
poll just this week that was published
those absolutely blowing people away it
was a it was a poll that was you know
one of the more left-leaning pollsters
so you know there can be no sort of
accusations and then it was published in
The Guardian says campaign accusations
of this was some sort of rogue poll to
to try to change public sentiment but it
showed one in two Australians supports
an immediate ban on Muslim migration now
this has absolutely shocked
so many people who just refused to
accept that this sort of sentiment is
out there and it's there because people
don't talk about this issue people
pretend that you know terrorism isn't
happening that it doesn't have religion
and and you know most Australians are
smarter than that now I don't actually
agree with the immediate battles or
migration I'm not for that at all but I
can understand and and the poll didn't
surprise me because you know I don't
know exists in this little tiny echo
chamber that so many of the media seem
to exist it where yeah I just think we
need to talk about these things openly
cuz when you don't
that's when you have sentiment like this
rising and I don't think it's
particularly healthy so isn't that the
ultimate irony of of your position for
you particularly because as an immigrant
from the Middle East it's it's extremely
personal to you but for me and the
people that are in our space that we see
on Twitter that are talking about this
stuff that aren't doing it from a
bigoted place that want to help people
when we can and all that but also what a
proper vetting they've put us in a
really bizarre situation and for you I
mean I've seen you go on TV and you know
I saw something where you were on TV
debating this
an anchor and he kept implying you were
saying all Muslims repeatedly even even
though you never said it will link to it
below so people can see it you never
said it it was the it was the age-old
argument that we have all the time here
and it's like man she's from the Middle
East she was born to Muslim parents she
immigrated properly now she's trying to
stand up for the very values that this
country is for and they're doing this to
you to this bizarre alliance between the
regressive left and Islamists it is
prevalent everywhere you know in the UK
the US and even in Australia and it is
bloody sick it doesn't make any sense
the only sense it makes is that they
share a common enemy
conservatives but yeah I think you're
talking about a appearance on morning
television where I had written a piece
about yeah yeah this Tara has a religion
and we've got to acknowledge it again I
was at pains as we always are to say I'm
talking about is Loomis I'm talking
about the extremists I'm not talking
about the thing timeless the more you
know you've all those qualifications
were made but no nevertheless you know
even just talking about it even even
identifying what is happening that it's
clear to anybody who hasn't got their
head buried in the sand was her pour
into this student um and he brought up
Christian terrorism you know bombings
and abortion clinics which I think you
know the last one was he could find was
about 15 20 years ago but nevertheless
you know you can't talk about Muslim
based or isn't a space terror without
mentioning the Christian you know it's
just he also it was pretty great because
you asked him when the last one was and
he had no idea then he busted out his
phone and a few minutes later came back
and yeah it turned out to be 15 or 20
years ago I'm curious you know because
you guys haven't been hit with terrorism
really until about two years ago in
Sydney and there was that hostage
situation and all that was how much did
that actually change the discussion for
you guys because you were seeing it
everywhere else again surrounded by
water seemingly safe
yeah did that really change the
discussion in the country okay did the
Lindt cafe siege in Sydney did as sued
him and there's been other events here
just a short time before that there was
a young kid in Melbourne who was
radicalized and he tried to kill a
couple of police officers stabbed him
repeatedly he was shot dead that was
probably you know our first taste of it
Lindt affected the public it wasn't just
targeted at police but we've been really
fortunate in this country we've had our
counterterrorism officers and
authorities Foyle several plots we've
just had some someone imprisoned for
what was it called the Anzac Day terror
plot a really significant day within our
within our calendar the plot there was
to run over a police officer behead them
take their gun and shoot more people
we've had a mother's day plot that's
with before the courts now which was
again you know going to be targeting the
public from the information that's out
there and so there's there's been and
and the biggest one we had was all about
a decade ago not longer no about a
decade ago which was quite advanced
plans to bomb the Melbourne Cricket
Ground which is our biggest sporting
stating in here so we've been really
fortunate that these plots have been
stopped in their tracks but those lone
wolf attacks as we call them they're not
so easily stopped and and has been we
had a police member shot in Sydney last
year you know in attack by a young kid I
think was 15 16 who was again
radicalized so we've had a taste of it
but nowhere like you know places like
France and Belgium where their issues
seem to be so advanced that you want to
have ever gonna get on top of it yeah is
that the irony too is that it's like the
better that our security services are
the more things that they stop and often
we don't know that they stop them until
sometimes months or years later and then
at the same time it makes the threat
seem lower so then people want to be
more time
and again tolerance basically is good
but you don't have a full picture and I
guess that's really what the the big
issue is absolutely you can become
complacent you know we don't live in
fear here we don't think you know but
we're going to be flying off around the
street-corner but again you've just got
to be awake to the reality of what's
happening around the world and that we
are not immune from it you know the
Terran denies around here we'll bring up
things like you've got much more chance
of you know dying in a car crash course
you bloody do you know we drive around
we've got millions of cars but you know
do we not think about terror and we
don't worry about that and make sure we
keep doing things to counter it you know
do we not worry about domestic violence
because more people are dying on the
roads from car accidents I mean it is
just a stupid argument there is just so
much that is intellectually dishonest
and and just fraudulent in my mind when
it comes to this space because people
will do anything not to talk about it
people will do anything to deny that
it's even an issue and it obviously is
an issue and this poll that came out
this week shows that it is an issue and
people are thinking about it even if our
elite media and politicians aren't
willing to discuss it yeah
can you think of anything else that
we're so paralyzed to talk about because
I really can't in 2016 is there anything
else that we treat with such kid gloves
that is of such importance and ice and I
get email from people literally all over
the world from almost every country
saying that their governments are doing
the exact same thing yeah it seems to
yeah not be every Western nation seems
to be dealing with it in Australia I
think the other issue that is seems to
be taboo but is a significant issue is
what's happening in a lot of our
indigenous communities again it's
something that people don't talk about
because if you do talk about it you can
get labeled racist very quickly even
though you care enough to want to
actually do something about an attack
police put it on the public to publicly
discuss it even we've got kids who are
being really mistreated
and they're not being saved by the
authorities they're not being taken into
care at the same level as you would
expect I mean sorry
let me rephrase that they actually are
taken into care at greater rates then
then the non-indigenous community but at
the point where the authorities take
them seems to be a you know a lot higher
than then you know but no white kid I
don't think would be allowed to be
mistreated in that way for so long
before they are saved and we've got this
and a stolen generation narrative in our
history that that the authorities are
scared now to actually save kids who are
being abused and and because of that
political correctness because they don't
want to create another stolen generation
of indigenous kids taken from their
parents but those kids are condemned to
just terrible lives you know that they
repeat the cycle they and I think that's
just such a great shame and there is
that there is a really significant gap
in in living standards and life
expectancy in outcomes for indigenous
community compared to the non-indigenous
community and I believe a great deal of
that has to do with this politically
correct policies where we can't talk
about what's happening we can't talk
about the rampant abuse sexual abuse we
can't talk about the alcoholism the drug
use because to even start discussing it
is is racist you know their arguments
will come over what about all the drug
use and alcoholism in the non-indigenous
community well yes of course
but that doesn't stop yes it's exactly
the same sort of phenomenon happening
there and it's just as destructive and
it actually hurts the people that they
are trying to protect from from
discussion right and we see that we see
that exact same thing when it comes to
the discussion on Islam because if we
don't talk about it then who are you
hurting the most you're actually hurting
Muslim people who are living under these
theocracies but the people who are yeah
killed the most
and oppress the most our other Muslims
and you know Islamic state looks at
Shiite Muslims like my family as
infidels no different from from Jews or
non-believers gays you know they think
they're deserving of nothing of death as
well so and extremist Islamists have
been killing other Muslims you know at a
rate that is extraordinary for decades
and we've just don't it's almost not on
our radar anymore because it happened so
often for Riddle whatever there is what
about the abortion bombing in the
Crusades well that's it well yeah what
about the Crusades
I mean God's sakes some of the arguments
that are thrown up I just just they're
just too stupid but you've got to
acknowledge them when you've got to
counter them because they've been taught
in universities you know I've had these
sort of arguments for university
lecturers and journalists and you know
peer academics who who are on the public
purse and I'm just spewing forth
[ __ ] and it's maddening spewing
forth [ __ ] that could be the title
of a book that we should probably call
write that book so jumping back for a
second talking about Australia's role in
the world what what is the Australian
sort of ethos about what you feel your
role should be obviously you guys aren't
that interventionist but you've been
part of coalition's and things like that
what is the the feeling there of what
your purpose in the world should be
well pretty laid back about things we
don't try to sort of set the agenda or
you know enforce our belief systems but
yeah we we have been a good corporates
corporate we've been a good global
citizen oh man slip is gonna be replayed
many many times on history we can be
quite proud of involvement in World War
two our involvement you know with the
Allied forces and I think you know we do
feel a little bit removed geographically
we are so far from so much of what's
happening around the
but these days you know it's all there
in your hand and your photo in its
immediate you know what's happening as
soon as it happens you know that's it's
we're living in a time where you know
those those borders or the stone seem to
mean as much so I think we're fairly
relaxed about our place in the world you
know we do have those amongst us as you
have them in every community who want to
set the agenda they want to be you know
we had a carbon tax for a while and you
know that rationale was there we you
know we're going to lead the world in an
emission trading scheme we're going to
be the standard bearers in a fighting
global warming and uh that government
got thrown out really quickly so yeah
that didn't it didn't last too long so I
think overall most Australians recognize
a pretty lucky we got a very good
standard of living we've got our own
concerns all sorts of issues from
housing affordability to the threat of
terror but I think we're yeah we're
pretty happy with seeing what's
happening around the world and and and
feeling fortunate that it's not
happening in our back yard yet yeah it's
I'm telling you it's that water thing
being big and surrounded by water it's
it's pretty good what do you what do you
make of our crazy election here and not
only what do you make of it but what
kind of coverage in Australia just in
mainstream media is our election getting
because it's all we it's all we have
here any of the cable news 24 hour days
that's all we talk about are we getting
a lot a lot more than previously there
is a lot of American election coverage
in our mainstream news particular
television great deal of it and all of
it almost all of it is pretty much what
you'd expect it's very much you know
Trump is just maniac who's a racist and
sexist and you know some of the reports
I've seen which is mostly just straight
news reports have been again
extraordinary in being little you know
edit or
rules that are absolutely biased
personally I don't know what I mean I've
got a great deal of thoughts I'm not a
fan of a of a candidate I can't be
enthusiastic for Trump but I completely
understand the phenomenon I understand
people being utterly fed up and wanting
an anti-establishment figure I don't
know why appeals to people I think a lot
of things that the the media see is gaps
and sees huge errors in his character
actually enormous assets and I would
appeal to a lot of people so it's been
just fascinating I would love to be
there for the last month or two and just
see how it unfolds but you know Trump
some of his greatest enemies are again
his greatest assets you look at what's
happening now with the protests in in
Charlotte and you know the process that
were happening at his rallies and you
think the average American looking at
that would actually sympathize with
would sympathy would understand some of
the things he's been saying about what
the country has turned into you know
Charlotte is just extraordinary you've
got a black cop shooting and seems to be
an armed black man and the place is
being torn apart and our black
protesters shot another black protester
but it's in a city with a Democratic
mayor yeah it is why she's fault somehow
you know this black on black violence
that's happened and somehow cause for
just Lutetia beatings and just mass
mindless violence that's been
characterized as some sort of a protest
that's got some purpose and it doesn't
it is just mindless looting and violence
and it should be called what it is and
again I think the public can see what it
is but the media narrative is trying to
paint it to something other than that
and I think that is a great thing as
something else we have in common in
Australia and America you Europe is the
media being out of touch with its
readers viewers listen
they are just increasingly there's a gap
between members of the media and the
mainstream population and I think that's
not healthy yeah I think it's
interesting to use the phrase out of
touch because I think one of the debates
we're constantly having here and the
reason that online shows are working is
that it's is it out of touch or is it
that they're actually in it with the
politicians do you think it's it's like
a sort of generational thing and just
the technology thing and you know we're
all walking around with phones so now
we're all on the ground doing this or or
is it that they're actually in it with
the people in power so they have a
vested interest in keeping that game
going or maybe both well in the u.s. it
might be a bit of that in Australia I
think it is that I think it's because
they're part of the establishment or the
elite I think it's just the ideological
disposition of a great number of the
members of the media and it's it's great
many of them are not you know they look
at the mainstream will one that an
acknowledged the mainstream is actually
mainstream know they think quite often
things because they're surrounded by
like-minded people that their views of
the prevalent views and they're not or
they just look at the mainstream with
sort of condemnation as if they're too
stupid to believe what they believe and
I think it's again really unhealthy at a
time where the mainstream media needs it
needs its audience more than ever to be
poles apart from from what their great
majority of the population thinks I
think is really unfortunate yeah and I
in Australia anyway I think it's just a
simple matter of the politics of the
individuals within the media tends to be
very much on the left as it has in your
been for the generations and and the
remember the rest of the population is a
lot more diverse than that it's a lot
more nuanced than that you know and and
their views aren't being properly
reflected of course there are
conservative commentators and writers
and journalists but I'm very much in the
minority and and not reflecting the
number of voters who are
leaning that way how much of this stuff
do you think is actually just purely the
fault of education be it in Australia or
be it here or wherever I mean I was
watching the the Charlotte the riots and
there was this guy you know they found a
protester and he was screaming about
Trump and I'll preface this with saying
this is not a defense of Trump but Trump
is not in power now he's not the
president or the governor of the state
or the mayor of that city and the guy
was blaming Trump and it's like I'm not
saying you should be blaming Hillary and
I'm not even saying you should be
blaming Obama but you're you're miss
directing things at somebody that has
literally nothing to do no power in
place has anything to do with Trump
right now and to me that's an education
problem not a political problem very
much and yeah if those opinions come
from ignorance but they are supported
again by quite often by mainstream media
now remember you know after even Orlando
there was talk about you know Trump as
if he had anything to do with it you
know after the Orlando massacre it is
just absurd to be blaming him I mean we
can you imagine how this news would be
reported if it was a bunch of Trump
supporters who were tearing apart a city
who were you know bashing by standards
or just the color of their skin who were
looting in there and just causing this
widespread widespread mayhem and
destruction yeah it is completely
idiotic but it's become a wasted joke
you know I mean something horrible
happens around the world
you know you blame brick suit you blame
Trump you blame the Crusades you know
you can't ever actually pinpoint the
blame at the people responsible because
that would be you know probably racist
and gross gross and racist we know that
I want to back up a little bit to some
of your history because you weren't Oh a
is a public person and a journalist and
someone that's you know staked out
controversial positions you're actually
you were a private citizen you were in
banking at first right yeah what allows
you to go from a normal job to somebody
that's
out there putting their their face with
their words I know I was a same industry
with good prospects and good income and
you know that man don't want miss Gracie
just wasn't for me I thought I want to
go I want to go into an industry where
there's massive job losses and where I'm
going to be the tiniest of tiny
minorities
it wasn't completely planned it was
fairly accidental but it was a happy
accident and you know I did decade in
finance and I think I enjoyed most of it
but by the end of it I just had enough
and I had much higher than at that point
too so it sort of gave me an opportunity
to rethink things I went back to
university I did my masters which was
again that's kind of cemented some of my
thoughts about higher education than
just how many junk degrees there are
just completely pointless just sadly you
basically said that you think higher
education is a waste all together right
oh no no not a waste all together I just
think in Australia in particularly way
there are so many of these chunk degrees
that don't qualify you to do anything
that saddl students with big debts raise
their expectations and they come out and
they're no more qualified for a job than
they went when they went in and you know
a lot of it is just left indoctrination
posing as education it's just absurd and
you know I'm all for having even more
degrees for you know doctors and nurses
and architects and accountants things
that actually you know teach you how to
do a certain job but you know bloody
masters in gender dance therapy or
something else is just crazy anyway um
so yeah it was all again it wasn't
planned I was by chance and just finding
myself I guess so that's such a wanky
term but anyway Here I am and it's it's
worked out well yeah so here you are
it's worked out well we connected on
Twitter I don't know maybe six months
ago
so and I thought wow here's someone else
across the world who gets it who you
know I sense cares about the same things
I care about I see you every now and
again you fight with some of the haters
I'm not big on fighting with the haters
as a general and I see them spewing all
sorts of genuinely racist awful things
at you
they often they often think that you're
another nationality than you are a
religion Pakistani yesterday I was
copying in fact yesterday I had someone
I told them I'm not Indian because you
know all their sort of abuse was framed
around me being Indian or Hindu like
never never don't know anybody there had
never been there no way and they just
refused to accept it
that I've no you are Indian acceptable
areas look it is a really fine balance I
tell people you know if I'm giving them
advice about to nurses like don't feed
the trolls don't acknowledge them their
attention seekers they're desperate for
any sort of attention so don't give them
what they're looking for but on the
other hand every now and then I don't
know my followers enjoyed it's good to
you know call out some filthy hypocrite
and just highlight the UTC highlight the
EDC and hypocrisy and vileness of some
of these social justice warriors who
think you know their their morals are
pristine and who think they're better
than the rest of us but they're quite
often and a fairly vile human beings and
I'm happy to mock them I'm happy to you
know highlight them to the followers and
let them have their fun with them um but
I acknowledge the other way your way
which is just don't acknowledge them
because you know I get literally some
days thousands and thousands of mentions
and I came and read all of them and I
certainly don't you know respond to all
of them and it does seem like sometimes
you know the overwhelming bulk are
decent comments intelligent comments
that you're not acknowledging in you're
acknowledging the lewd lunatic and that
seems to be sort of Kanchi
counterintuitive but I think we've got
to highlight the mentality of these
people particularly when they
to be morally superior to the rest of us
right so that that's an interesting
piece of this because we've got the
social justice warrior class that are
moralizing all of us and telling us how
racist we are in all this nonsense and
then at the same time there absolutely
is a piece of this all right thing that
I've talked about a bit a bit on this
show where I get it there there Pepe the
Frog and Harambee and they're trolling
everybody and then they get Hillary to
talk about the Frog and they're just
internet meme posters their [ __ ] posters
and they want to upset everybody and
they I think they're perfectly harmless
but I also do see the the real white
nationalist stuff and I don't know how
many to that so my questions he really
is do you think it's just I go back and
forth basically between thinking that
it's healthy when they get this stuff
out because then it's not just hidden
and secretive and even though they're
anonymous whatever they're getting it
out versus on another hand in the last
year I have seen more blatant true hate
than ever before online so I'm not sure
which one I whether I think this is
actually healthy or or not yeah I
haven't set my mind to that - I'm not
sure I mean it does seem like an
absolute sewer at times Twitter ie you
know yeah more so than any other social
media forum it seems to be just bile
fields were full of people who are
miserable who just what a fight yeah
that those really not nasty nazi types I
haven't encountered too many I've had a
few and I've just bought them but
they've been very few in numbers as far
as the ones attacking me so that I'm not
sure of the size of that population I
don't think it's anywhere near the size
of the of the other side but yeah any
sign of them isn't healthy and again I
think they should be treated with
absolute disdain that should be called
out there should be mocked and that's
what I tend to do I don't try to you
know convince these people and try to
re-educate them I just mock them because
that's all they deserve they don't
deserve your time they don't deserve
you know and I think Twitter's are
really dumb forum for in-depth arguments
you know you just can't have them it's
just that's not the place for
discussions yeah you try to frame your
point of view in us fewer characters as
possible and if you're actually trying
to have a proper discussion I just don't
think that's the forum for yeah do you
see a new center sort of lining up all
over the world because I think even a
year ago or so people were barely
talking about this I'm talking about the
people that are not the far right true
white supremacists or racist or whatever
you want to call them and you know I
don't like using all the buzzwords and
not and not the regressive left and all
the sjw's and all that but that there is
some sort of new center lining up and
it's because of the internet because
people like us have been able to to
connect that my friend Ally R is be up
in Canada who's the atheist Muslim
coined the phrase the new center he said
that's that's the new home politically
do you says that this could actually
become a political movement absolutely I
think political parties are starting to
recognize what the electorate cares
about and they know you've got to think
the Republicans have to regroup over the
next decade and recognize that they
abandoned their base that you know they
had so many people so desperately
unhappy with them and so you get to jump
on the on the Trump train and in
Australia as well you know in the last
election something between one or two
million vote two million voters and
that's a significant figure here we're a
small country of conservative voters
took their vote elsewhere from from the
mainstream conservative Liberal National
Coalition so I think there is this new
center and where it is is the question I
think it's a far more to the right then
the media class would want it to be and
acknowledge it to be I don't mean their
right wing I just think they're you know
in their economic point of view in their
attitude to borders and immigration and
national security they're far more
conservative than the media class would
like them to be and acknowledging them
to be so I think the politicians have no
choice but to acknowledge it yeah they
can't ignore it their political survival
depends on it so but whether you
actually see the emergence of the new
party is something else to to ponder I'm
not sure about that but this talk of
that in Australia let's talk about an
actual new Conservative Party that will
bring in all these sort of minor parties
voters but it hasn't happened it's
something that's been talked about but
whether it actually eventuates is
another yeah I think it's interesting
that you know a second ago you started
to say that they're more right but you
really meant conservative and then you
you fix yours yeah yeah change but you
know but I I bring that up only because
it's like even people like you to make
your point you still want to be so
concerned about the language and I feel
that too because we're we're so just
under this thing where if you say one
thing wrong and imply that the
Conservatives are really far right or
that that everyone will be all over you
and that what if what a crazy place for
people like us to be in
oh it's insane it is people are just so
hypersensitive
oh yeah and so looking to be offended by
something or take something out of
context that you do sometimes you know
even if someone who doesn't want to
doesn't give a stuff about political
correctness you find yourself qualifying
things and explaining things like you
over explaining things it's yeah it's
it's I guess we're not immune to it
either when we live in that world and we
have to acknowledge it I wish we were
over I see people on Twitter telling me
sometimes Dave we could see it get over
yourself like you know just stop but you
know I'm still trying to be a person
that a good person that exists in 2016
so so my last my last question for you
is taking everything that we've
discussed here what do you think the
best thing for for people that are that
are hearing our message is whether
they're a little more right or
conservative or a little more left or
liberal or whatever it is for all of
these people that are hearing this and
seeing the same
friends that you're talking about all
over the world what is the best thing
that they can do to help fix some of
this stuff ah be brave be bold say what
you think I think that's the the message
to take out of it don't be afraid don't
be bullied into silence don't feel like
your point of view isn't worthy of being
aired and discussed and don't worry
about you know if you say something
you're gonna be unfriended on Facebook
by someone you went to school with 20
years ago you don't I just think people
need to be people need to be braver and
have and be interested yeah if it I
wouldn't force anybody to to become
political nuts but you know if you care
about this stuff get interested read
read different sources find out what's
really happening and don't be shy about
putting your two cents in yeah well
that's what I say on on the show every
week so I will cosign that one all right
well Rita it was a pleasure I'm so glad
we finally connected and we were
supposed to have you a couple days ago
in our internet blew out I think we
somebody's watching us and they didn't
want us to connect it was I don't
believe that was just coincidence
there's obviously some sort of left-wing
conspiracy to silence us yeah I think
there's any other explanation possible
sort of left-wing conspiracy any way you
guys can follow Rita it's at Rita Panahi
on Twitter and she can follow her
writing over at the Australian Herald
Sun and Rita it was a pleasure so we'll
we'll keep doing this in 140 characters
you